the winner in the category of Medicine
making it ties that's like the big thing
you kind of had that status of being in
like the group I would say that a lot of
people are jealous of on deadlines I'm
awful I wait until the deadline to start
working I listen to trap music in
classical music passing up volume
I actually don't listen to classical
music that much I just listen to mostly
trap yes
if you're there just to win the prize
you're missing the point of science can
you enter into this new kind of world
I didn't even know cave existed it's one
of the best weeks of my life like every
time I go there so you know meet you
sorry you Chris say you agree did I spot
us how it's gonna be I'm gonna be so
proud when one of my kids win a Nobel
Prize because they will finalists from
78 countries regions and territories
around the world can think of it as the
Olympics of science fair
[Music]
the planet
[Music]
winning will change your life in ways
that you don't even come free
[Applause]
today's like the judging day so we're
gonna get judged for what like six hours
today
you